every week we select a game to take a
closer look at and break down in this
spot this week one of the best games of
the weekend one of the most exciting
games of the weekend the game that i
hoped saints bucks was going to be nope
it was dolphins cardinals
exciting game pitting kyler murray
against tuatanga vialoa let's get right
to it we break it down into various
categories to provide the framework for
discussing the game best player on the
field that day shireen who do you have
well i think it has to be one of the
quarterbacks mike and i went with two as
simply because quarterbacks are judged
on wins and losses and he won the game
and he's 2-0 despite his ugliness of
week of his first start uh he looked
much better in this game 20 of 28 240
yards two touchdowns but the key thing
mike no turnovers kyle murray had the
big fumble that led to a defensive
touchdown and the other big play he had
was on third and one with 105 left he
did the quarterback sneak for a first
down and they were able to take knees
and run out the clock he had seven
rushes for 35 yards i just thought he
was very impressive in his second start
that's what i expected in his first
start we didn't see it maybe it was
nerves whatever maybe it was playing
that rams defense whatever the case he
looked much better in this game and
played a heck of a game and is a big
reason the dolphins have a lot of hope
not only for this season but for the
future
yeah and he seemed to get better as the
game went on he settled in he was more
confident they trusted him more and when
it was time to try to go win the game in
the fourth quarter he did it first he
had to tie the game up with a touchdown
drive that made it 31 all and then he
put the dolphins in position for the
game-winning field goal tua was awesome
now does it mean he's the guy for the
next 15 years not necessarily because
the injury issue is still there when he
fractured the hip last year one of the
first things the general manager said to
me is look three years at alabama three
lower body injuries that is a concern
for a quarterback who has and who uses
mobility so
let's keep our fingers crossed that he
can stay healthy but he has looked very
good
in his second start the first start was
an incomplete the second start was an
a-plus got the win on the road against a
good cardinals team and for me it's the
other quarterback one of my favorite
players right now in the nfl tyler
murray the guy is incredible they
incorporated a lot more in the way of
designed runs this week that's a point
chris sims made earlier today on pft
live and the film bears that out just
get him the ball let him go he knows how
to avoid contact now he was a little
more aggressive running the football and
he did get popped a few times but for
the most part he's smart about avoiding
taking the kind of hit that could
potentially get him injured he had a
beautiful throw to christian kirk for a
touchdown uh ju just just everything
about him is fascinating he throws it
well he runs it even better
and
you know he arguably did everything he
could to put the cardinals in position
either win the game or force overtime
and we'll talk more about some of the
things that kept that game from being
even more compelling than it could have
been but but it wasn't kyler's fault he
didn't make some huge mistake that
caused the cardinals to lose the game he
did everything in his power to will that
team to victory
yeah i would say the one play obviously
which maybe it wasn't his fault but the
one hit he took early in the game the
fumble that was returned for a touchdown
probably ended up being the difference
in the game but you know he he usually
gets away from those and i was surprised
that they were able to track him down
because they usually don't track him
down like that and make him lose the
ball and the dolphins did a really for
the most part did a really good job i
know he had over 100 yards rushing uh
but but they made some big plays on
defense too and that was one of them and
they just seemed to keep coming up with
those big plays on defense
see and i'm glad you pointed that out
because yes that's on him to a certain
extent but when it's 31-24 in the fourth
quarter the cardinals are winning that
that's ancient history
down the stretch when it mattered the
opportunities they had
that's when i think he did everything in
his power and there were others who
maybe let the cardinals down and kept
kyler murray from being kyler murray and
allowing the cardinals either to force
overtime or to win the game all right
someone who was better than you thought
before you took a closer look at the
game sheree
well you know jason sanders doesn't
usually come to mind when we start
talking about the best kickers in
football but this is a guy who just set
a franchise record 20 field goals in a
row 17 this season three obviously last
season so he's on a a big streak now and
they were not easy kicks he had a 56
yarder and a 50-yarder and the 50-yarder
ended up being the game-winner and you
look at what zane gonzalez did or didn't
do for the cardinals he missed a
49-yarder short that really cost him a
tie game and a chance to go to overtime
and he was just terrific and i i think
that
when we start talking about the best
kickers in football we need to put his
name right there
yeah i agree with you completely look
what matters is making the the kicks
that win games and he did that and uh
that's the clutches moment that you can
imagine on a field for a kicker and he
delivered i'm going with emmanuel ogbo
he had two plays that really stood out
we've already talked about the forced
fumble i mean anytime you can hit
kyle murray and cause him to lose the
football that's a good day you could
just walk off at that point but then he
tipped a pass later and he's just a guy
who's on the rise for the miami dolphins
the guy who was with the browns and he
he lost out in a numbers battle once
they had miles garrett and they picked
up olivier vernon and they really didn't
need agba anymore and the dolphin said
fine we'll take him and i think they're
grooming him into a potentially special
player but but that's a guy who who
stood out to me
watching the game again especially with
those moments in the first half shereen
yeah and you know when they signed him
in the off season mike they gave him two
years and 15 million i think guaranteed
7.5 million i thought what are they
doing that's too much for this guy but
he's been everything they thought he was
going to be career high seven sacks
career high three-fourths fumbles he's
been really good for this defense and
really a different difference maker for
them this season
yes okay who had a day that they would
like to forget after your further and
closer inspection of the game shireen
well you know mike in retrospect i think
xavier howard did a really good on the
job on deandre hopkins and i think it
was a reason that deandre hopkins did
not have a huge day but i know that
xavier howard likes playing better than
what he played and he had those past
interference penalties he had three of
them uh one of them was an offsetting
penalty and one of them i thought was
kind of ticky tack he definitely had one
of the three but i know that that he
likes playing better than that and i
know those penalties really bother him
but he did do a pretty darn good job on
deandre hopkins i think they said 13 of
15 first half routes he was on deandre
hopkins and
they really held the andre hopkins down
which i think was a key to this game
yeah i i am gonna go
with andy isabella the cardinals
receiver for two things in particular
that were squeezed in at the end of the
first half and the start of the second
half at the end of the first half when
the cardinals were trying to maybe get
in range for a field goal and who knows
whether or not they would or wouldn't
have there was about a minute left he
catches the pass and he clearly has the
first down then he goes backward and
retreats and gives up the yardage fourth
down and they punt and the dolphins
drive down and get a field goal
that that's a potential six point swing
if the cardinals would have kept that
drive going at a minimum it's a
three-point swing by giving them the
ball back and that was just a
bone-headed effort by you know these
guys who are fast they always think
their speed is number one going to get
them out of any jam and number two
it's an excuse to go backward because
that one step back is going to open it
up for 10 steps forward and it's just
unfortunate and then he had a fumble on
the opening kickoff of the second half
that originally i thought the dolphins
recovered i know some of the dolphins
players did that would have been a
disaster and you get lucky when one of
your teammates ends up getting the ball
at the bottom of the scrum but you got
to hold on to the football that could
have been game over that could have been
lights out for the for the cardinals a
lot earlier than it would have been if
the dolphins would have gotten the ball
there sharing
yeah and i i saw that play mike and i'm
like oh the dolphins got this game this
game could be over here if they go punch
this in and he did he just got lucky on
that play you you've got to hold on to
the ball we know turnovers are a big
factor in in games and you can't
definitely can't fumble the opening kick
off the second half so he got really
lucky a teammate got in the bottom of
that scrum and somehow came up with the
ball because i don't think they
originally had it
okay give me a play that stands out to
the the to you that you want to focus on
a little bit more
yeah there were 5 20 left in the game
mike and the cardinals uh had fourth and
one and four plays before that they had
a fourth and one and conor murray picked
it up on a run right they hadn't stopped
them all day they were two for two at
that point on fourth down you think
they're in the same formation which i
hate shotgun on on fourth and any kind
of short situation i hate the shotgun
but that's what he does he does every
play out of the shotgun i get it so i'm
fine with that but the fact that you
hand the ball to chase edmonds who had
no chance to pick up the first down why
are you trusting kyler murray at that
point to pick up the first down he'd
done it twice for you earlier
get keep the ball in kyla murray's hands
let him run around he's going to make a
play and more than likely he's going to
make the first down
yeah i agree with you and i think the
reason why they didn't give it to murray
was because he got hit hard the play
before and you rarely see that happen
that may have freaked out cliff
kingsbury i hate that shotgun formation
run though third and short you know i
don't know why they won't line up curl
kyler murray under center
unless literally he would be under
center because he's so short but
but
you you you have to give the running
back a chance to get it and when you're
starting flat footed when you get the
ball you don't have the same head of
steam when you bang into the line when
you need just a few inches the the play
that that i first want to mention
briefly the decision to kick the field
goal on fourth and one
late when zayn gonzalez comes on a
49-yarder nobody who's short on a
49-yarder i don't know why they kicked
the field goal
but but beyond that
nowadays it used to be a big deal to
make a 49-yarder back when they kicked
straight on now a 49 yarder may as well
be a 35 yarder and it's a it's amazing
that that thing fell short the one other
play that i want everybody to go back
and take a look at because i'm trying to
figure out what really happened here
preston williams when he scores his
touchdown he jumps up he celebrates next
thing you know he's limping on the
sideline he's carted off
there's speculation that it was
something that occurred during the
celebration but watch jaylen thompson
number 34 the cardinals he kind of does
the tristan hill
chris carson
barrel roll shireen i don't know if you
had a chance to look at that but but
there was one extra roll that was a
little too much and maybe it didn't
register with preston williams that his
ankle had gotten twisted but uh i i i i
suggest everyone we gotta take a break
but go look at that if you have nfl game
pass because it it looked like it was a
little too much from thompson and maybe
that contributed to the injury to
preston williams
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports